[Music]  simba you have to take your place as  king  we need you  [Music]  come home Oh everyone calm down we're  here backup has arrived can you feel the  love tonight look at the stars the peace  the great kings look down on us from  those stars  [Music]  that's so will I Disney's The Lion King  rated PG tickets on sale now the King's  time is ruler rises and falls like the  Suns one date the Sun will set on my  time here and will rise with you as the  new change  [Music]  remember who you are Disney's The Lion  King rated PG in theaters July 19th  [Applause]  [Music]  it is time  [Music]  everything the light touches  is all kingdom  but a king's time is ruler rises and  falls like the Sun one day  the Sun was set on my time here  and will rise with you as the new king  [Applause]  [Music]  remember  [Music]  [Applause]